comment mieux associer les salariés au
succès de leur entreprise on en parle
avec vous Laurent Berger bonjour bonjour
secrétaire général de la CFDT ce partage
de la valeur c'est pas un sujet qui est
nouveau ça fait longtemps qu'on en parle
des décennies diront certains et je me
rappelle Nicolas Sarkozy en son temps
qui parlait de la règle des trois tirs à
propos de la répartition des bénéfices
entières pour les actionnaires un tiers
pour les investissements et un tiers
pour les salariés ça n'a jamais vu le
jour vous le regrettez pas à l'époque à
la tête de la CFDT c'est une bonne
répartition vous pourriez signer ça
aujourd'hui bah le principe d'un tiers
un tiers 1/3 peut paraître un peu ne pas
tenir compte de la diversité des
entreprises mais en tout cas ce principe
que dans le partage de la valeur créée
il y en ait un tiers pour les
actionnaires un tiers pour de
l'investissement et un tiers qui aille
au travailleur pour le pour parce qu'ils
ont participé à la création de valeur
effectivement le principe est
intéressant après est-ce qu'il faut le
faire avec autant de de de précision je
suis pas sûr on peut aussi estimer que
la négociation entreprise permettrait de
d'affiner selon la situation de chaque
entreprise ce qui est sûr aujourd'hui
c'est que on le voit dans le partage de
la valeur ajoutée depuis des années
la part des salaires à peu près stable
oui mais il y a eu un phénomène
d'optimisation fiscale grandissant qui
fait que il y a une part grandissante de
la richesse créée dans certains nombre
de grandes entreprises qui échappent
d'une part à la richesse nationale d'une
certaine manière par la fiscalité mais
qui échappe à la redistribution de la
valeur donc on a une distorsion qui sont
qui s'est opérée de salaire puisque la
part des salaires dans la valeur ajoutée
depuis la fin des années 80 chiffres
Insee montre que vous l'avez dit que
tout ça est stable il y a un sujet
salaire y compris la négociation qu'on
est en train de mener nous on dit on
peut pas mettre de côté le sujet salaire
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a au-delà de ça
le sujet participation
intéressement dispositif de de
répartition de la valeur créée envers
les salariés qui est aujourd'hui très
insuffisante après il y a la question
sur la question du salaire
évidemment il y a l'inflation et donc
à l'inflation ce sujet la plus partage
de la valeur comme on augmente pas les
salaires revient sur la table mais déjà
sur la question des augmentations de
salaire le compte n'y est pas
aujourd'hui on a cours on a 6 %
d'inflation sur 2022 3,7% de salaire
nous a dit le ministère du Travail ça
rattrapera pas l'inflation d'autres
mécanismes à côté le compte n'est pas ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que d'abord les
salaires doivent suivre les mécanismes
d'inflation c'est-à-dire que il doit
avoir des négociations salariales dans
les entreprises dans les branches
professionnelles qui permettent de
compenser l'inflation c'est-à-dire que
c'est donc vous souhaitez on veut pas
l'indexer nous on veut des négociations
vous savez aujourd'hui il y a à chaque
revalorisation du SMIC on est à peu près
à 130 branches qui sont en dessous qui
démarre avec des minimas en dessous du
SMIC là il faut des mécanismes beaucoup
plus dynamiques dans les branches en
termes de négociation et donc il faut
des incitations en direction des
branches professionnelles du côté
patronal pour négocier donc il y a un
sujet salaire qui est posé à travers ses
branches et à travers les négociations
annuelles obligatoires
aujourd'hui si on fait le bilan sur 2022
il y a des endroits où ça s'est passé
avec des négociations salariales qui ont
été à la hauteur des endroits où on a
des stations salariale qui ne compensent
pas l'inflation et il y a eu parfois des
augmentations à travers la prime de la
prime Paypal ou donc qui compensaient
plus ou moins il y a des endroits que ça
ne compense pas du tout il y a des
secteurs professionnels où il y a une
perte de pouvoir d'achat qu'est-ce qu'on
fait énorme là je crois qu'il faut
vraiment inciter à une revalorisation
des des grilles salariales dans les
branches professionnelles vous savez
quand vous avez trois ou quatre échelons
qui sont en dessous le SMIC avant même
de avant même de discuter dans les
entreprises du salaire ça veut dire que
vous restez au SMIC pendant des mois et
des mois des années des années sans
compenser de reconnaître d'abord votre
compétence parce classification et sans
compenser les pertes de pouvoir d'achat
donc il y a vraiment une logique de
politique salariale qu'il faut
distinguer de de
la discussion qu'on a aujourd'hui sur le
partage de la valeur ajoutée mais il
faut le distinguer mais la question
salariale doit être intégrée quand même
dans les discussions qu'on a avec le
patrona wake c'est un peu compliqué
comme moi le travail le salaire c'est ce
que vous vous recevez en fonction de la
tâche que vous effectuez c'est ce qu'on
vous paye pour faire ce travail le
partage de la valeur c'est ce qui vous
revient quand vous êtes un salarié parce
que vous avez créé de la valeur ça passe
donc pas seulement par le salaire les
hausses de salaire mais il y a aussi les
prix
les participations m'intéressement le
numéro 2 du Medef me disait Patrick
Martin quand on met tout ça bout à bout
ça compense l'inflation tous ces
mécanismes c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai le le en moyenne faudrait
regarder ça se discute mais c'est pas
les moyens qui comptent vous voyez bien
que les salariés de ce pays ils en ont
un peu assez qu'on les considère en
moyenne c'est-à-dire puisque il y a eu
des augmentations qui dans certains
secteurs c'est vrai parce qu'il y a de
la valeur créée ou parce que il y a
beaucoup de participation
d'intéressement
masque finalement la réalité de salariés
plus modeste ça marche pas vous savez
les dispositifs de participation
intéressement ça existe pour à peu près
en moyenne 55% des des salariés mais 83%
des salariés des grandes entreprises en
bénéficient et 17% les autres des
salariés de moins de 10 donc vous voyez
c'est pour arrêter de fonctionner en
moyenne aujourd'hui dans tout un tas
d'entreprises il y a pas de mécanisme
distribution de la valeur de la valeur
créée c'est pour ça que nous dans la
négociation réclame la participation des
dispositifs de participation ou
d'intéressement obligatoire de
l'entreprise et un calcul simplifié
aujourd'hui cette obligatoire la
participation au-delà de 50 salariés
vous plaidez-vous pour abaisser ce seuil
pour élargir la participation
de participation pour toutes les
entreprises obligatoires et que ce soit
avec un mécanisme de calcul qui soit
très simple que dit patronat le patronat
est opposé à ça la négociation est
aujourd'hui dans une forme d'impasse en
tout cas dans une grosse difficulté le
patronat aujourd'hui les seules
propositions qu'il fait c'est
non obligations de mécanisme de
participation et
allégement fiscaux
qui existent déjà renforcement le
renforcement du forfait social
renforcement des allègements fiscaux
pour distribuer de de
enfin le fruit de la valeur créée aux
salariés franchement c'est pas sérieux
donc on est dans une négociation qui est
aujourd'hui est en panne du certaine
manière on a jusqu'au 31 janvier on a
une dernière séance le 31 janvier moi je
le dis au patronat de toute façon c'est
très sérieux je leur dis en direct aussi
si vous ne trouvez pas un point d'accord
si on n'arrive pas à trouver un point
d'accord et vous ne faites pas un effort
de toute façon on plaidera après auprès
du gouvernement pour qu'un dispositif
obligatoire existe mais mais prenez
conscience que c'est beaucoup moins
intelligent que sur l'été capable de
trouver un point d'accord ce que propose
le gouvernement c'est notamment cette
prime Macron versée en 2021 à 4 millions
de salariés pour un montant moyen de 500
euros montant qui a été rehaussé en 2022
à 710 euros est-ce que c'est bien on se
dit qu'on est loin du plafond de 6000
euros potentiel et puis c'est au bon
vouloir de l'employeur donc c'est
d'abord dire lorsque des salariés 4
millions de salariés et touche 500 euros
de plus à travers une prime dire que
c'est pas bien
pas le faire quand on a un syndicaliste
parce que j'imagine que pour un certain
nombre de salariés ça a été bénéfique
mais un c'est pas obligatoire vous
l'avez dit deux ça sert à rien de fixer
un plafond astronomique pour finalement
ne pas avoir ne pas y arriver et 3 nous
on pense que c'est dispositifs de prime
ça doit être en cas de non de non de
non-accord de non-accords participation
c'est à dire que ça peut pas être le
dispositif pérenne vous voyez ce que je
veux dire il faut un dispositif qui soit
obligatoire là c'est au bon vouloir donc
il y a eu des périodes spécifiques avec
le covid la période poscovide
l'inflation etc on a bien vu que ça a pu
marcher pour 4 millions c'est pas neutre
mais ça ne marchera pas les années à
venir si si on rend pas ça obligatoire
le temps qu'il est parti naissent le
patron de la CGT dit et c'est vrai une
prime c'est ponctuel alors que le
salaire c'est tous les mois mais en même
temps de manière exceptionnelle une
prime ça peut aider à booster le pouvoir
d'achat
oui vous savez c'est toujours faut pas
être déconnecté de la réalité quand vous
vers les deux non mais en tout cas il
faut dire salariale et et il faut il
peut y avoir dispositif de prix mais
nous ce qu'on préconise avant tout c'est
des revalorisations salariales et des
dispositifs de répartition de la
richesse créée d'entreprise qui soit
pérenne donc pour tous c'est
participation pour tous c'est clair bon
d'ailleurs le gouvernement va mettre en
place le dividende salarié en gros dès
qu'une entreprise verse des dividendes
aux actionnaires elle doit récompenser
aussi ses salariés ça vous plaît c'est
saugrenu vous n'êtes pas contre parce
que c'est une façon de contraindre
quelque part les patrons à redistribuer
la valeur peu importe ce soit le bon
terme ou pas ça existe enfin on peut le
faire en élargissant les dispositifs de
participation ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut se dire c'est il se passe quoi
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on entend par
dividende verset vous voyez dans tout un
tas d'entreprises ça sera pas la
dividende notamment les entreprises
assez petites ce sera pas la dividende
versée à des actionnaires dont on sait
pas où en fonction du cours de la bourse
donc il faudra trouver une méthode de de
calcul qui soit autre nous on est plutôt
en fonction de des bénéfices créés par
entreprise qu'il y a une part qui
mécaniquement automatiquement reverse ça
s'appelle la participation ouais bien
sûr voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai essayé
de l'expliquer différemment mais ça
s'appelle la partie situation mais oui
mais c'est ça qu'il faut faire il faut
un dispositif simplifié dans le calcul
déjà on est là il faut l'élargir le
rendre obligatoire aux entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés bien sûr aux
entreprises de moins de 50
minimum de participation avec non je
crois que avec le calcul sur une base
100 il y a 100 de valeur créée il faut
qu'on calcule qu'il y a tant qui
reviennent aux salariés parce qu'ils ont
participé à la création de cette image
une formule de calcul qui est très
complexe
objectivement faut la simplifier parce
que généreuse
pour les salariés oui je vous remercie
de le proposer mais non mais c'est
surtout faut la simplifier parce que
l'idée c'est pas de complexifier ce que
disent ce que disent ce que vivent des
chefs d'entreprise dans les petites
entreprises mais ici c'est simple c'est
un pourcentage et que c'est et que c'est
facile à calculer il y a aucune raison
de pas le généraliser et aussi un autre
mécanisme qui plaît au gouvernement
c'est la super participation en gros
elle traverse salarié des entreprises
qui réalisent des super dividendes en
gros des dividendes qui sont supérieurs
de 20% à la moyenne des 5 dernières
années pardon c'était pour être précis
là aussi vous êtes ouvert quel que soit
le nom l'appellation en fait
nous on est ouvert à ça et il faut il
faut effectivement que quand il y a des
déversements beaucoup de versements de
dividendes ça il y a aussi une part qui
a eu salarié mais on aurait tort dans le
débat actuel de polariser seulement sur
les grandes entreprises dont on connaît
les grands noms et dans on se dirait
c'est celle là celle-là parce que bah on
a tort les stigmatiser en tout cas on a
tort de croire que de faire croire qu'on
aura réglé le problème de partage de la
valeur ajoutée quand on aura traité le
sujet dans ces entreprises là c'est ce
que dit le patron la CGT en disant
regardez 80 milliards d'euros de
dividendes vers fonctionnaires sur le
CAC 40 mais sur les dividendes versés
aux actionnaires il y a deux il y a deux
actions qu'il faut mener c'est il faut
de l'inversement salarié à proportion
c'est une évidence et puis il faut
regarder aussi ça veut dire de
participation qui soit et les boutiques
d'ailleurs souvent dans les grands
groupes super participation etc oui bien
sûr pour ça c'est pour ça vous savez il
faut pas se masquer derrière quelques
quelques réalités qui existent et sur
lesquelles il faut traiter les choses
pour qu'il y a un meilleur partage de la
valeur ajoutée dans les grandes
entreprises mais en se disant quand on
aura réglé ça on aura réglé le problème
de travailleurs dans tout dans toutes
les entreprises c'est pas vrai le
problème il est d'abord pour les
entreprises des petites les petites
entreprises des entreprises de taille
intermédiaires les PME etc où il faut
trouver un mécanisme facile à mettre en
œuvre qui permettent la le partage la
valeur ajoutée dans les grandes
entreprises si vous voulez sur les faits
bon vivre pardon pour les salariés dans
les grandes entreprises ils ont la
participation les salariés ils ont
l'intéressement ils ont il y a beaucoup
de choses oui mais bien sûr parce que
parce qu'il y a eu de l'action syndicale
aussi bien sûr parce qu'il y a de la
richesse créée ça veut pas dire que il
faut pas qu'on réfléchisse quand même à
des dividendes qui sont qui sont chaque
année en tout cas depuis deux ans
toujours plus important l'idée pour la
CFDT c'est pas simplement de le partager
la valeur mais sur les le le le
dividendes notamment ce que rapporte le
capital je crois qu'il y aura besoin
aussi de d'aller vers une politique
fiscale qui soit qui soit plus juste et
qu'on avait celle l'impôt sur les
sociétés
la France qui revient de loin oui oui
mais il y a la CFDT elle a jamais été
pour le contre-rétaurer des marches aux
entreprises vous savez le pacte de
responsabilité le cice etc ça peut avoir
du sens mais quand
les super dividendes ou il y a outrance
d'une certaine manière dans le versement
des dividendes parfois avec des
mécanismes d'optimisation fiscale etc il
est pas anormal de se reposer la
question de comment il peut ça peut
contribuer aussi à la richesse nationale
s'il y a trop de dividendes c'est au
détriment des des salariés des salaires
on va pas dans toutes les entreprises ça
peut être dans certaines entreprises ça
peut être au détriment des salariés et
de leur salaire de leur de leur
participation y compris parce qu'elle
n'existe pas mais dans d'autres dans
d'autres cas ça peut être au détriment
de la valeur de la de la richesse
nationale quand on parle de
l'enrichissement des actionnaires on dit
souvent il vient des dividendes mais si
on regarde bien les choses ça vient
plutôt ça vient des dividendes bien sûr
mais surtout de la valorisation des
marchés boursiers et si les bourses sont
beaucoup montés regardent le poids
boursier du CAC40 dans le PIB c'était
50% en 98 on est à 100% aujourd'hui
c'est de la faute entre guillemets
notamment des banques centrales des
politiques de taux d'intérêt très très
faible donc l'enrichissement des
actionnaires est venu pour partie
vivante surtout de la hausse de la
valeur de leurs actifs liés aux
politiques monétaires extrêmement
similiantes stimulante pendant des
années et des années donc on est sorti
d'ailleurs là aujourd'hui mais c'est
pour ça que il faut pas que c'est plus
complexe que vous savez il y a deux
choses il faut pas deux risques qu'il
faut vers lequel il faut pas aller le
premier qui serait dire il y a rien à
bouger là-dessus et la répartition de la
valeur créée est non elle est pas juste
aujourd'hui donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
souhaité s'engager dans cette dans cette
négociation et qu'on espère que si elle
n'aboutit pas
mais le gouvernement commence à
spontanéité puis à l'autre il risque
d'avoir lequel il faut pas tomber qui
serait de trouver anormal que quelqu'un
qui investit n'est pas un juste retour
de son investissement et sa prise de
risque mais il y a une distorsion
aujourd'hui une profonde distension qui
s'est créée notamment dans certains
secteurs professionnels mais surtout
dans certaines entreprises et donc le
rétablissement de la répartition entre
le capital et le travail il est
absolument nécessaire pour que ce soit
plus juste et pourquoi ne pas plaider
alors en berger pour une un
développement une massification de
l'actionna salarié comme ça on aligne un
peu les intérêts entre les actionnaires
et les salariés vous savez quand vous
êtes salarié vous vous
vous effectuez un travail et vous vous
êtes rémunéré pour mais vous n'avez pas
intérêt à mettre tous les autres dans
mes paniers non mais c'est vrai c'est
clair on l'a connu ça on l'a connu dans
certaines entreprises vous avez votre
actionnariat votre épargne une certaine
manière qui est en action dans votre
entreprise vous travaillez et puis c'est
votre salaire aussi et puis le jour où
ça où ça flanche vous n'avez vous vous
n'avez plus vous n'avez plus de
possibilité de de survivre et puis il y
a un autre élément chez à le dire c'est
vous savez ce sont du partage de la
valeur il est aussi la question du
partage du pouvoir et de la
responsabilité de l'entreprise
c'est-à-dire que la gouvernance ouais ça
va de pair pour nous ça va de pairs on
le dit d'ailleurs dans la négociation le
partage de la dans la gouvernance la
participation des représentants du
travail à des choix stratégiques à un
moment donné les fondamental on a
progressé depuis 2013 avec la
participation des salariés dans les
conseils d'administration on peut aller
plus loin aussi si on résume ce qu'on
s'est dit il y a pas de consensus au
sein des
des partenaires sociaux pour l'instant
non la négociation n'est pas terminée
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a pas de on
n'est pas sur la bonne voie pour un
accord parce que donc ça risque de finir
avec le dividende salarié oui mais là
encore
le moment venu je dirais au gouvernement
il faudra faire quelque chose
d'intelligent qui soit qui soit quand
même dans praticable pour que le but
finalement c'est que la richesse soit
mieux répartie de l'entreprise notamment
dans les pays que ce soit pas juste
cosmétiques notamment dans les petits
évidemment notamment dans les petites et
les moyens d'entreprises je vous
remercie pour cet entretien secrétaire
général de la CVT merci beaucoup voilà
c'est la fin de pourvu que ça dure
l'émission qui rend les co-responsables
sur Public Sénat émission à voir ou
revoir sur Public Sénat il y a du replay
bien sûr sur publicena.fr rendez-vous
dans deux semaines
[Musique]